do you know something else that I think
we have in common I want to ask you a
very very deep spicy put you in an
uncomfortable position question you like
macaroni and cheese I do I love macaroni
and cheese yeah I'm going to one day I'm
going to explode my diet is my my diet's
gotten better I would say in the last
year and a half two years I've started
to eat much better you have a birthday
coming up December 27th what are you
going to do for your birthday I don't
know well this movie will be freshly out
I usually spend it with my family and my
parents uh yeah last year I had like
eight people over did you ever have a
like a yeah we had I had a bowling party
once that's fun my thing with bowling is
that I don't want to stick my fingers in
the hole and then eat it's all finger
foods and you're like true I've never
thought about and that and it disgusts
me okay back to the film I um I really
really really grew up worshiping and
idolizing Jean Wilder like he was
someone who I thought brought so much
heart and humor and depth what did you
go into it with dos and
don'ts I don't know about don'ts but
definitely this is the companion film to
the Gene Wilder you know story and sort
of the story of how this young Willy
wonu started out ambitious cleare eyed
hopeful you know full of joy uh this is
the story of how he was before the Gene
Wilder version that we all love and grew
up on and uh uh Do's was to approach it
with joy and optimism and have as much
fun on camera as possible because the
movie is fun and it's generous um it's
such a delight you're such a delight
thank you Huma I feel like I need an
Academy Award for you in this role I do
see a nomination coming I'm not kidding
is this the most true to your character
what the hell did you bring to this oh
Drew you're very nice you're very nice
to me I didn't bring much I just brought
you know grumpiness kinly sort of I
based him on a angry little Scotsman I
once knew oh really yes like a real
person yes his name was Archie he he had
red hair and no one liked him much poor
Larie he was a bit lonely and but bossy
and uh so it's it's him really and a
little bit of some school teachers I
knew and uh okay K I want to know how
you can play reserved and dry but be
that addictive and funny a little of it
is all of the help that I got from the
hair and the makeup and the Wardrobe you
know it it as as he expands and expands
I was trying as as much as I could to
just use the makeup and use the the
Prosthetics to my advantage see I would
put all that on and still go big like I
don't have a subtle bone in my body
right oh
I disagree profoundly yes profoundly my
inner voice tells me the
[Music]
opposite